situation mm-hmm like nigeria
i feel like submission
you need to respect in order to submit
fully not all the time i do well there
can be aspects of submission where you
don't need to respect them it can
literally just be
yes sir that doesn't mean you respect
them
your outward behavior i mean like you
you might not respect them in your mind
but if you're submissive your your
behavior will show that doesn't mean not
having a voice i didn't say that i'm
just saying you're outward because you
just said oh you can just say yes and
not respect but you can be disrespectful
at the point you're being disrespectful
you're not being submissive can i can i
have an example
can i have an example of how like you
guys are submissive in your day-to-day
life
well i thought you said you said
complicated
what no you're saying your day-to-day
life yeah because you're not your
relationship yeah yeah so yeah because
you were saying you could be submissive
in the realm so first of all you clarify
sorry can you clarify to us what you
deem as submission well submission
basically is follower it's like you are
you're following leadership yeah okay
um
sorry but i follow leadership at work
no that's a that's a good example yeah
that's a good example i am a supporter i
i actually work in as part of my program
i actually support the program so
that's my day to day mm-hmm um
honestly
i feel like submission should be both
ways
in a marriage okay um and that is that
can be done differently though um i feel
like for example
my husband
may be submissive in a sense where
any decision that he chooses to make he
can he we talk about it first it's not a
thing where oh it's my house it's my i
paid for i think and i'm going to do it
the question is when you guys disagree
with how who makes the decision because
at some point you guys are going to
disagree who makes the decision i he
makes a decision yeah he has to get the
last word yeah so
so you are submissive to him yeah yeah i
never said i wasn't that's why she's
married
wow that's why that's not that's not why
but yeah
okay well you disagreed with that one
it's hard you know because i know like
pearl mentioned she was like oh like i i
just think it's a thing that you are and
you can't choose but
the state of some men nowadays who can't
make a decision to take a go out on a
date like oh where do you want to go
blah blah blah like like it is that bad
like it's it's that bad out there like
certain man can't can't can't can't plan
a date like they'll be like oh where
would you like to go and stuff like that
like it's that yeah but feminine women
don't deal with guys like that
that's feminine women but more women are
becoming more women
so you know how you said that um you
feel like submission is something you
just have or not right you said that um
i i don't believe that you know i don't
and the reason why i don't believe that
is because i know how i am now and how
it wasn't before
and i was nowhere near submissive but i
think it was because of the situation i
was in maybe it was in me and i didn't
know
that i could i can't argue with that do
you think you're confrontational maybe
because we're on the pod you're thinking
that but on a normal day i'm chilled
on a normal day i'm trying i don't
believe you i don't i don't believe i
don't believe so i generally i i do
agree with you i don't believe that if
the right guy came along and said look
like first date i want you wearing this
i want you here at that time you're
gonna you're gonna kick off i think that
would be that's me i can't even lie
but this is why i said gingerbread is
like
you're giving me the like yes yeah
exactly i don't think you're going to
start kicking off being like no actually
i'm just curious independent woman like
no you wouldn't you wouldn't you'd be
like okay yeah no i'd do it yeah but
that's why
a man that talks to you like that
doesn't respect you and therefore
doesn't it
so he's nice enough to take you on a
date and you're mad about the way that
he took you on a date nobody was going
like whoa
wait like that's what it was
like
i think it's nice i'm saying it's nice
just because you took me on a date
you have to let me talk this is my show
it's rude if you keep sorry sorry so i'm
saying if he's nice enough to take you
on a date
like why why are you complaining about
him telling you what time to come and no
no no no and what to wear no you can't
tell you can tell me what time to come
it's a date at the end of the day i know
but if he says what to wear like i like
the way you tell me that's what i said
it's not it's not you if that's why i
said if you're
oh this is what you're gonna wear you
can't talk to me like that no i think
you're just taking it that way but
that's that's nothing in the way
but you realize that that's really
confusing for men because like like we
pick up on things that men don't like
tone of voice and like eye contact and
like smaller things so when you say oh
you can't talk to me that way and you're
saying the same thing but it's how you
say it like to men that's very it's not
well if it's confusing then i'm sorry
you need to go back to school
because everybody knows you're the way
you talk to somebody can have a
different result you can get it i think
it just came out aggressive i don't
think that was his intention his
intention was i'm taking charge we're
going here that's what i want you to
wear um this is what time i want you to
be ready bye no no not in a controller
do you go try it yeah what way not in a
controlling way but in a in a way it's
like it's like acting in good faith with
someone not like immediately just
jumping that oh he's trying to control
you i didn't say he's trying that's not
that's not what i think he just came out
aggressive but i'm just saying how you
say something for example it's not
saying i'm not saying you can't tell me
oh can you wear something like this or
this is a time we have to meet
as i said everything is how you talk to
somebody because remember this is the
first date so how you talk to me i'm
going to be picking up on that as well
so that's what i'm not saying it's going
to be controlling if you the way you say
it may come across controlling that's
why you have to be careful when you're
talking to people first impressions
matter and that's just if that's
confusing for you then sorry
i mean if you don't like it then you
don't have to turn up in the game no
no no this is what i'm saying and this
is why marriages don't work oh if you
don't like it then you can know you can
have a conversation with somebody and be
like oh do you know what could that be
you don't know me you don't know that i
don't like it so i'm gonna give you a
chance to get to know me and i'll
explain to you what i like and what i
don't like it's not about oh i don't
like it i'm not going on the date no
i'll still go but we'll have a
conversation and i'll just let you know
okay this is what i like and
so don't tell me to what to wear and
stuff like that well i didn't even tell
you i'll deliver it how i'm gonna
deliver it yeah i think you might have
misinterpreted that kind of what i said
the reason why i say i'm going to tell
you what to wear is because most of the
time i'm not going to tell you where i'm
going to go where we're going to go yeah
but you know what she needs so you know
what i mean you didn't let me finish
okay
sorry i didn't interrupt you though
somebody else did but we just that's
fine
okay i'm gonna read super chats for a
second guys you already know what we are
saving for okay
get
ish a camera let's go you wanna know
what ish looks like
send a super chat all super chats will
be read
for the most part
um
so and to start we got a hundred dollar
super chat let's go
okay thank chris thank you to the ladies
on the couch you help keep other women
delusional and remain as side chicks to
guys like me you are my virtual winged
woman i could not live the lifestyle
without other women co-signing the lies
i tell them don't back down i need you
sorry
okay kane kane marco modern women can't
stand facts and statistics their concern
is fleeting happiness the sisterhood and
fairy tales the things that men want
actually want from them flies right over
their heads sentience what rubbish when
women ask how's your dating life
question it's not a genuine question
especially in a debate it's a brie it's
used to bring awareness and shame to
someone other than the one who asked the
question bad faith alistar horton sadly
happiness is nothing more than dopamine
high and like any drug is addictive you
don't let your emotions control you
sentience oh sarah is back the